arien sind ihre welt
wenn ich singe fühle ich mich anders wie
ein neues ich
lindern de-leser studierte operngesang
in kapstadt
wie der 26-jährige tests telekom eine er
ist angehender bassbariton
ich hatte es schwer ich bin in armut
aufgewachsen es gab zeiten da waren
meine mutter und mein vater arbeitslos
aber sie haben immer dafür gesorgt dass
wir etwas zu essen haben
der seele wuchs in einem township auf
wie etwa jeder vierte schwarze
südafrikaner
arbeitslosigkeit schlechte ärztliche
versorgung kriminalität
auch für linda war es ein weiter weg bis
zum gesangsstudium möglich nur durch ein
stipendium sie ist die erste in ihrer
familie die überhaupt studiert
und das an der renommierten universität
kapstadt
als ich erfuhr dass ich am use it
college angenommen wurde habe ich mir
die seele aus dem leib geschrien
durch die stipendien können sich immer
mehr studenten aus townships die uni
kurse leisten
sls eltern sind das erste mal in
kapstadt sie wollten immer eine gute
ausbildung für ihren sohn eine mit der
er mal geld verdienen kann
sänger hatten sie sich nicht vorgestellt
doch jetzt sind sie schwer beeindruckt
treffen mit einem dozenten
wer wird in der lage sein sie finanziell
zu unterstützen
die zeiten ändern sich man muss nur fest
daran glauben
ich sage ihnen er hat das zeug zum
superstar
pele hat sogar schon mal bei den
vereinten nationen gesungen zu
apartheidzeiten durften schwarze nicht
einmal als zuschauer ins opernhaus in
kapstadt ein gesangsstudium erst recht
undenkbar heute genau in diesem haus
noch eine premiere für pcs eltern ihr
erster opernbesuch überhaupt mit den
hauptrollen der seele und linda
finger weg
bis es das ist meine erste große rolle
das könnte meine chance sein zu zeigen
was ich kann
auftritte an der oper kapstadt sind teil
des studiums
und für so manchen absolventen ein
sprungbrett an die großen bühnen der
welt
mit stades ich gehe vermutlich in die
usa aber ich will auch in london vor
sich in europa
ich möchte arbeiten damit meine eltern
die kinder sein können ich möchte für
sie sorgen
eines tages werde ich für euch singen
und euch allen erzählen dass ich ein
mädchen bin dass im township
aufgewachsen ist und es bis an die
metropolitan oper in new york geschafft
hat das wird eines tages zu sein ganz
gewiss
ja